[Music]
welcome everybody to frenemies
we're back again and this is the
halloween
extravaganza the finale the finale
the fourth week running it culminated in
us dressing as each other
who would have guessed everybody on the
internet but i gotta say i'm really
enjoying having these
big juicy knockers you look really good
you look like me like you look we look
like each other
and i cried a little this morning when i
realized i was like wow we really have
the same body type
the fact that my dress fits you is like
making me sad well it kind of
doesn't really it's more like a shirt
but i guess you were kind of naked when
you wore it yeah
yeah i always have my ass out too your
mustache is falling out it is
well because someone uses my glam team
and i have to get up at 6am to do this
so it's been honored for four hours
yes because i've had this before a.m i
had to film videos i ate i did tick
tocks
but you would have done put it on at
that time anyway because you're like all
tick tock upset
no i do it right before but you get the
glam priority before me by coming on the
show and so then i have to just sit
around and the stuff kind of falls off
yeah well i am the priority i know
trust me i know everything is on your
time they said you got up late so then i
want to go get food and then like
everyone's ready and you were late you
were like super late
because you got up late he's like he's
not even up yet what you weren't um
we're you're always here at 11 30. dr
drew
he's by the way dr drew's with us today
i'm so excited he's with us he was with
us since 12 which is when we usually
start and you've kept this poor
doctor yeah a doctor's time is so
valuable in this world you've got a
blade i know i was sitting here ready
who told you i got up late the i'm right
our makeup artist she's like she's not
for business
yes it is because i was gonna come early
i'm on time oh my god
so don't worry we begin shall we begin
i'm so excited i'm seeing a lot of here
sorry sorry go ahead
i think i'm seeing a lot of room for
improvement
i'm so nervous is this like real is this
comedic this is real
okay here's what we're gonna do today
first of all dr drew the acclaimed
doctor is with us today dr drew
after dark on your mom's house he also
has a
daily stream show on youtube and pretty
much everywhere
he today is going to be our marriage
counselor our couple's
therapy counselor because as you guys
know we've been through a lot of drama
there's been lots of fights
and i thought it would be good to have
fresh eyes professionalized
to go over our history of friendship
together and kind of
help mediate our feelings right i'm so
down i
love dr drew you have told me my entire
life to go on dr joe because i have like
everything wrong with me i have my vvt
i have my trans issues i have eating
disorders i have sex addiction i have
everything that
everyone's like you should go to i'll
feel problems i'm done i can be on every
show
calm down okay so you know what's funny
we were talking before you arrived that
um
we want to do personality tests okay and
a future episode
oh you can do like associate a
narcissist personality test oh i'm not
that
well we'll find out i'm too empathetic
for that i know all of the like i don't
know all but
i go to a lot of therapists like dr drew
what do you think
about this situation so far a couple of
observations uh
interesting how you play with that hair
all the time that's interesting that is
a distinctly feminine trait
i'll tell you why before you try to make
any uh psychoanalysis of it
it's just it's in my face right so i'm
i'm
trying to just get it out right i i
understand dr freud that sometimes a
cigar is just a good smoke
but i'm just saying that perhaps there's
someone else
do you notice anything about trisha so
hold on
and i what i love about you guys is that
you're you're playing with gender
which is really very much topic of the
day you know it's very
top of mind topic for a lot of people uh
let me just
there's some things i want to say about
your interaction but first of all i want
to know how it feels to adopt another
gender trish how does that feel what's
it like
well obviously last year one of the
reasons
they came for me was they i i had issues
thinking you came for me saying i wasn't
transgender
oh well he yeah the point of all this is
is like last year
well not just last year my whole life
i've had gender identity issues i've
gone to a really good therapist
he's in west hollywood he's amazing he
specializes in gender identity and stuff
like that
and like i've always always struggled
with it i've oh like i thought i was
trans but i never wanted to do
surgeries to you know be to transition
but um
yeah like this to me this feels
comfortable like i love being a guy like
not not just a guy but just not having
to be
the female body not going out and being
like scared like people are gonna follow
me and [ __ ]
and so yeah yeah so it's interesting so
so um
i don't i don't know you well and i
don't know whether there's gender issues
it's kind of interesting that that here
you are
playing around with it um but women
like yourself that sort of um
accessorize their femininity like
exaggerated a little bit
sometimes you can look at that as a
female female cross-dresser
does that make sense yes 100 percent
like that's the gender expression is
excessively female and what you're
saying is now i'm not sure if that's me
do you also have other kinds of uh
identity questions is it just gender
yeah so generally identity is kind of
not not really clear okay
so interesting so we're playing around
with that stuff today
isn't you i feel like i'm surprised how
great these titties feel
all right right like i could get down
some people there is such a thing as
getting really um
excited by taking on a female
uh exterior you're saying like i would
have a like a
like a boner i don't have a bone okay i
haven't been able to
yet he loves dressing as females he's
been doing girl makeup this whole time
you are super upset that i come on here
and
look better than you every single time
first of all i'm not upset i just know
you really are into it you love the
nails you love doing the makeup i like
i like when i'm doing the costume i like
to go all out and i have
a theory dr drew that part of the reason
we've been fighting
is because you're upset that every week
we come out here i look way better than
you
and by the way all the comments say
ethan doubted trisha
again and part of her identity is like
i'm she even said in a previous episode
i'm the girl who does the
hair and makeup i this is my whole thing
and when i come out here looking like
this she gets
upset and well she did come in the room
saying she's upset that you're the shirt
fits you she's upset your makeup looks
good
she was very clear about that no he uses
my hair and makeup people because they
couldn't find their own i gave them so
many people and they're like we don't
have anyone so finally i said here use
mine i gave them that and they go after
me
every single time so i come on here
looking like [ __ ] can i go
after you oh after me they come to me at
5 30 in the morning you've never
mentioned that
i always said it okay so that's it but
you owe it you do your stuff
at that time anyway because we shoot
earlier we always shoot at nine anyways
i'm not upset i if i was upset i
wouldn't have given my hair makeup
people i would have been like oh here
just use some shitty people that you
already use for your teddy fresh or
whatever
and that's not the case they use my bomb
ass glam team isn't it make our show
better when i look good
yeah i'm not mad that's why i gave you
them that's why i gave you my
accessories and my wigs and everything
this is her by the way this is what was
that what was that sigh all about you're
a sign
i'm exhausted every day every week dr
drew i don't think the show is good for
my mental health to be honest
come on every week oh my god my
session's coming out every week
we go through fights it's the craziest
most like okay you know what let's let's
let's just okay let's here's what i want
i love him too like i honestly look at
him as like
somebody i've known forever like i feel
like he's my best friend like it's weird
we have this weird like
soul connection but also he like
irritates the [ __ ] out of me i don't get
it
well there's there's something about
your interaction that you can
immediately change which is
the blaming oh right you blame each
other for everything
and every every statement begins with
you and that finger point you you you
you're just why don't you use it
i'm gonna bug you i'm gonna bug you for
the next however long we're together
to start with as opposed to you i've
noticed
okay i've noticed okay i've noticed
everything's about you
i've noticed he's an [ __ ] it's
definitely worse that's more passive
aggressive i don't like it
okay here's what i wanted sometimes
before we get stuck too much on this
let's go through the chronology of our
relationship okay
we first were interacted when i made a
video here ian pull up uh
the thumbnail first of all i made a
video
called instagram vs reality which is
you know on instagram people put on
these makeup and photoshop and filter
and they look so much different than
than how they look in real life
and so here was the thumbnail of trisha
i put her in the thumbnail
and then here before we talk about it
hold up pull up the time stamp uh the
next time step but
we can watch that together
yes this girl is the spokesman of
instagram reality
why do you why are you even a model if
you're gonna modify your looks that much
it's like from beauty queen to wwf
wrestler
you cannot photoshop your heart and soul
remember that
this girl tried to use a face filter on
instagram and her phone blew up
there's another one of her oh my god
ah she is the best isn't she not the
best would people even recognize her if
they saw her on the street i mean
she is unrecognizable this is coachella
versus throwing down in the mcdonald's
parking lot at 3am
this is coachella versus world star
hip-hop
no that cannot be the same
person dude coachella versus open casket
funeral
oh damn tan is looking like stop and
stop it
okay oh my gosh so amber so i didn't
know her at all i didn't even know her
name
and then i did that you're one of those
people on the internet my man
wait me no no he is oh but
feeling free to attack people he doesn't
know exactly wait
what do you mean one of those people
of those people that i've i'm swatting
off every day that
doesn't doesn't understand that people
that are out there on the internet are
actually people
exactly and can i just tell you too for
the record he took that
that side by side i posted on instagram
and i said i'm both i
purposely took myself looking ugly like
dr not ugly but just like ask myself
like before i go to bed
and the other one was maui on a photo
shoot with fabio like those were
exact two different things and i posted
it myself with the caption like hey i
can be both like that's the thing that
was
my caption my everything and he turned
it as like wow they're really tricking
us guys and i was like but i posted that
side by side and the most extraordinary
thing about it is that she was on a
photo shoot with show to shoot with
fabio
that's the part that's extraordinary
okay can i can i so here's the deal it's
just it's just a terrible place to begin
a relationship if you ever apologize for
that
so let me just make a have you apologize
for that yeah
i think i did you did when you came on
the show you definitely never apologized
i will say that when you the fact that
you pull
you now that i know you you are very
upfront about how you look without
makeup and the whole process of being
quote unquote beautiful and all that
and so there are a lot of people who i
think are deserving of the criticism
because the whole
theory of the video was like there's
these i'm getting to a point
is that there's these women on or i mean
both genders who do this thing and it
makes
uh young impressionable people who are
on instagram all day
uh think that that's the beauty norm
which is right
point taken right yeah the the
idealization through
technology is not good for developing
minds
we all three agree on that right yeah
yeah but so
we have a common ground the point that i
got wrong when talking about you
is that you are very upfront
about how you look without all that and
so i was wrong
trisha this is this is ethan offering an
apology but it's not an apology it's him
like it's true
it is it is it is keep going ethan
well i was wrong about you i think some
of the people there are deserving of
that criticism
but now that i know you i what i don't
think that you are a person who should
so yeah i do apologize because i
i do think that that that's not who you
are because you're very forthcoming
thank you and i accept the apology and i
love it can i just say one other thing
to stand up for the other girls in the
video one being nikki
before you i think that apology really
moved you
like yeah no even because you said you
loved it you really do love it
no i do like ethan like never apologizes
and when he does it's like
one time you've apologized to me and
like okay that means a lot and it does i
feel like i apologize
readily when i'm wrong but i feel like
he owes and i just say like i do
appreciate it i love it but
there's other women in that video that
he owes apology to one being nikita
dragon who's very forthcoming about
her she's a transgender she's very
upcoming about she showed a
picture of her before when she hadn't
gotten the surgeries versus a butt
picture of her after but she's very open
about that can you show that clip
because i don't remember
yeah and so you need to apologize to
that like to all that well let's see
let's see let's let's let's rewatch it's
a big thing
i'm afraid i'm going to interfere too
much with the conflict with you between
you guys the magic of the show is going
to go
no no we need help no you're doing great
i could quit today you know what i mean
like it's just one of those things
i'm still irritated by stuff that
happened last week i'm still irritated
recently and it was like let's get into
it we have to save that we have to save
the relationship so
let's get into it we'll get into that
that's what's on your mind now we should
start where you are but first let's
watch this video okay
yeah i want to see how let's see oh
that's me making fun of myself girl
apparently okay pause it pause deposit
so like i mean that's her before that's
before but like she's so
it's so photoshopped no she transitioned
into that i've seen akita in person
she's
surgery can you go back i want the whole
scope of what i was saying
that's her bbl off his roof but i don't
like what she's doing but that's not
right
i'm ugly and fat okay you got to work
with what you got here
so this girl apparently is known on
instagram for having like a
being thick you know and my goodness
just looking at this there's nothing
real it actually breaks my heart you
know because i know plenty of guys out
there that would look at that girl on
the left and be like
boom you know what i mean what guys
we put our dick in a meat grinder if it
you know had a chance of feeling good
little known fact is that
so um i feel like it wasn't that
offensive that was before her surgery
and she's so open about getting surgery
she's a trans spokesperson she's super
open about it
that's not fair to be like those are two
different people it is two different
people but i do feel like it's hurtful
to young girls to see like a fat ass
like that and be like
why don't why isn't my body look like
that
dr drew yeah it's an issue right
uh and and it's um something that uh
it's not exclusive to instagram right i
mean it's happening all over the place
and
uh i people are doing things to enhance
themselves all the time
it's it's my profession that's offering
those services
and then instagram just essentially uh
previews what uh what's going to happen
under the surgeon's knife
yeah and but i also to that to that i
say like they mean they're i mean i'm
very open too about having like search i
feel like as long as you're open
i think the worst thing is when you're
not open if girls just think like people
look like that you know but i just i
i you got it wrong like everyone's very
open about their stuff
so what was your intent patricia in
getting all that
in my surgeries yeah for yourself what
was that um
oh gosh well for me i always talk about
this like it was just like a self-hatred
thing like i just wanted to look skinny
so i got liposuction i needed big boobs
to look like girlier you know just like
all this stuff that i thought i needed
and i'm still unhappy and miserable and
like right now i'm all depressed i'm
like i should get more surgery and it's
like
it [ __ ] you up but i feel like i'm very
open about it
and i feel like a lot of those girls are
too like their psychological like
torment through going to positive
surgery like it kind of [ __ ] you up and
i feel like a lot of people are open
about it now but then to have like a
straight
guy talking about it yeah he's talking
about it's all i'm saying
and and he sounded a little jealous too
by the way yeah exactly that's the thing
he's like i'm fat i don't photoshop it's
like well like that's self-hatred into
itself like you're self-deprecating
yourself don't you think it's like a
vicious cycle where you're like i want
more surgery because i feel this way in
that way and then but like it's it's
this vicious cycle yes it is she said
that yeah she said that
it's i'm still exactly there she said
that it does not fill the void
no it's supposed to solve problems it
doesn't solve the problems
maybe it does for a few weeks but then
it just becomes who you are and then you
still hate yourself
or whatever are you still you i don't
apologize to okay
nikita dragon or whatever her name is
okay i'll take that again
well tana i said she looked like a
twinkie but she was wearing
a yellow swimsuit you want to pull up
the tana comment
ian we can we could just close the case
on that one drew you could tell me if i
need to apologize or not on this one
i'll let you decide
all right all right
i'm glad we have someone here that has a
reason
everything yeah so crazy well with you
i generally am always right yeah you can
just thank you i mean
you know what i mean and by the way i'm
generally in favor of apologizing for
online access thank you i think it's i
think it's you know
it's the direction we need to be going i
was saying in favor of apologizing right
or what did you do
yes yes if you've been excessive online
it's okay to apologize
yeah i mean that's well
you don't think you've been accepted
turn it out that's not where the
apologies out you know what i'm saying
okay
wanted to mean something i guess yeah
yeah
all right here we go damn tana's looking
pretty good these days oh
i can't believe it's the same day she
looks like a twinkie
all right this
apology warranted
um the yellow outfit was the
in a weird way that's making too much of
nothing which is guess what photographs
lie
and if we don't know that by now uh then
caveat emptor you know what i mean
and and i think uh i don't know that
woman i mean if you feel like you hurt
her feelings you should apologize
you don't want to hurt her i'd assume um
but
i don't think i've heard her feelings i
think you just yeah i don't think she
cares
right so so i don't think it's a big
deal yeah but there is something to be
learned from that which is that photos
live videos lie
too but if we don't know that photos
live by now let me
ask you this if the joke is funny does
it
warrant the comment like she looks like
a twinkie pretty funny observation
pretty good maybe that's what softened
it for me maybe good yeah
okay good fantastic yeah and and because
it was funny
it landed good for you and she is like a
naturally thin girl so like not to say
she doesn't have issues but like
calling me you said i look like i washed
up on the ocean like that's like
i'm a lot bigger you did so that's
it's different she's obviously thin so
it's like not that big of an insult
calling someone who's right
it's saying that she's looks perfect in
this photo oh my god she's a human being
well guess what she's a human being
right yeah well if i did say you washed
up on the ocean that was the one i felt
bad
about i guess is that i thought maybe it
was mean okay not looking like a corpse
no that was funny because you were
laying there like this like come on
i'm with him ethan was funny that was
that was that was a hope
you literally looked like you were of
course okay i you know what i accept the
apology so thank you for that
let's not get out of ourselves here okay
let's move it on to the next big drama
we had
uh is he's normally concerned with
authenticity is that his big concern
i need to be authentically myself okay
so go ahead so the next big fight we had
was uh when trisha made a video
announcing that she is a transgender
female to male now i now before i even
talked about this
she got a lot of flack from everybody on
the internet was
dog piling on trisha saying like that
she's uh com what basically the
criticism was that you're
using trans issues to basically get
attention for yourself in the making
yeah so you lost on both sides right
people who
who are critical of trans issues and the
trans
allies both attacked you yeah well my my
trans friends were
supportive of me as was my therapist you
know they were pretty supportive so i
would say it was more actually
the allies it's more like cis people
being like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you know or a lot of
like gay guys too but uh
no i think trans people were wearing no
a lot of people let's see let's see the
video do you have a video there
yeah we'll pull it up dude trans people
were dead i could name three that were
so supportive blair white
la demi oh those are people you know
exactly they know me
yeah but they're just being nice
i did a video and i don't know if it's
still i think it is where i wanted to be
referred to only as t
because i didn't know i didn't
i didn't feel like i identified as a
girl now this seems like
crazy and weird and shocking because
now previously just to give context
you've also made videos coming out as a
what other you made videos coming out as
like a cheese puff or some [ __ ] what was
it well when i was like heavy on drugs i
like would say i'm a chicken nugget
which is clearly
true came out as a chicken nugget this
video i'm sober i'm on tour i'm like
coherent the other ones my pupils
everything's like i'm obviously [ __ ]
up in those videos
okay but regardless did make a video
coming out as a chicken but it wasn't a
sit-down one it wasn't like using
personal thing
yeah i mean i that's what i do i did
online for a long time it's just so
people
didn't take her thing seriously and i
understand that that i understood
completely i get why people didn't it
just hurts that
in context but you can't really come out
as a chicken nugget i didn't come out as
a chicken nugget it was a spoken word
poetry
when i was [ __ ] up on meth and i was
like hey today i woke up feeling like a
[ __ ] chicken nugget y'all like that's
what it was and i was like so [ __ ] up
if you watch the video
completely different than this video
where i'm like sitting down like hey i
have something like i want to say like
this is like on my chest it's been on me
for a while
and there's been tons of videos of me
talking about penis envy about me
wanting to be a boy
what not wanting to be trish like all
this stuff and there's been multiple
videos
that i talked about this and expressed
this and this one just i guess triggered
people because everyone wanted to hate
me last year including h3 nicotto
pewdiepie everyone attacked me all these
people so it's just with the year of
hating trish last year
so here's the deal with uh when people
declare things on drugs everybody
they're on drugs they're [ __ ] up
but let's let's just leave it at that
don't do not try to
hold on to them what about people who
are drunk and say
things like no they're on drugs that's
that's a mistake
oh their true feelings coming out no
that's the person on drugs
now there may be some de-repression
there may be some
things coming out that they wouldn't
otherwise speak but the way they speak
and the way they speak about it
is somebody on drugs so give them a
chance if they've revealed something
to come back around and talk about
what's really going on and your brain
isn't
integrated your whole self isn't there
when you're loaded so we're getting
you're getting a pass from dr drew
yeah but like if you watch if you pulled
that video up it's so i'm saying
the two things are not really related so
the chicken nugget thing is
fish on drugs and what i'm seeing here
in this this video we're watching right
now
is something we talked about earlier is
that your your identity
is is you know not not fully
crystallized right your identity
generally and of course that kind of
bleeds over into gender
let's go ahead and continue the uh video
ian
you know that stuff like that but that's
why i identify more as a gay man because
i like guys but i also identify as a guy
if that makes sense the thing that kind
of like stops it is i do
love which a lot of gay men do too i do
love like
glam and voluptuousness so in my head i
feel like i'm
a transgender female to male but also
like a drag queen that's how that's kind
of how i've like
that is exactly right because
that is exactly right she's a gay i
identify as gay male
drag queen that's that is exactly what
that is and you don't exactly i think
you're i think your construct is exactly
correct
uh whether or not that's your firm you
know forever identity i don't know
but that's what you're describing which
is i don't really feel like a female but
i feel like a female
cross-dresser i like all the female
stuff uh but i identify as sort of a gay
men
now the question is are you attracted to
gay men so yeah
the gay man would be would be attractive
to gay men yeah i
i dated um she's dating a straight man
probably right now i am but i dated a
gay man for two years i was very public
you know so i
i and i dated a gay man how did you guys
navigate that how did you
how does that work for him and that's i
think a lot of people like i mean he
would say this i'm asked this as just
strictly curiosities
are you saying like sexually like
intimately yeah like well like what how
did you
it's a navigation right and so it's an
interesting we're all like how'd you do
that
yeah well we were we were definitely
friends i was like oh you're definitely
gay and he's like
he goes he goes well you know he goes
but i am like i like you and i was like
well i don't know so then we just
started like
hooking up within months into our
friendship and then realizing that we're
like oh we're like dating that's what
we're doing and it was hard and that's
the ultimate demise the internet was
like he's obviously gay trish
and the thing was is like my my energy
and just like day to day i mean i've
always dated
feminine guys like i feel like i have
just masculine energy by nature i'm
usually like
you know i but i don't i don't know like
to say that a lot of people i'm like to
me he said he was bi the other day
i talked to him and he's like actually i
just i just like who i like you know so
it was never we did have like vaginal
sex but it was a lot of yeah it was a
lot of
more uh you know pegging and penetration
that stuff
okay all right interesting you saw you
back did you did you like that was that
stuff you like doing that
i love it yeah and even now with my like
my only fans i
i'm always the one to wear the strap on
like with girl and girl stuff like i'm
always the one doing
the i just i just feel more powerful i
feel more turned on that way
interesting yeah interesting it's a lot
to take in
ethan you okay it's a lot to take in as
she's dressed as me
it started like this the image of your
pegging
and all this is just a little bit much
well i love i like i've dressed as
boys you know what cis boys look like
you know before and i like it i love it
i like you know i've done it multiple
times and
i don't know it feels it feels
comfortable to me but so does sodas
dressing as a female like a cis female
dress is comfortable too
so good okay so you be you right yeah
thank you all right so
but hang on a second i want to jump
ahead of something that's on my mind
before we look at more video real quick
you said something's really bothering
you from your last show or something
yeah we're working we got to get that
out and they open whatever that is i
feel her feeling it it's bugging me so
go ahead
there's a lot to cover but okay first of
all if we go we fast forward
to um let me go there the walk out
the walkout so basically there's a few
key moments i think the
the main one is when we go go ahead and
show dr drew
when we start talk when she says that
i'm a pill addict start from here
is that true it's not true okay actually
i'll give you the context we were here
and please don't interrupt me but you're
okay let me hear your side first this is
not where it started though
earlier i i don't want to i don't i
can't watch the
so go back but what happened was that
we're sitting back here hanging out off
camera
and i mentioned to her that back you
know 10 years ago when i was living in
israel and had a day
and i was like in a dead-end office job
for five years
that i was taking pill like uh
painkillers
that was ten years ago i'm not currently
taking how much how much
i i honestly don't know i was getting
high like on the weekends that's it i
was taking pills on the weekends you're
using it you're
using opiates to get high on the
weekends you weren't taking them you
weren't strung out
no i didn't take them when i was working
so so trish that
we we back in the hade you know the the
sort of the center of the eye of the
storm of the pharmaceutical opioid
epidemic
people were using a lot of opiates that
weren't addicts now we would still call
that a substance use disorder because
you're
you know illicitly using opiates to get
high but i it's hard to call him a pill
addict
per se with just that history and and
now you say you've been addicted
now do you so do you really believe he
was an addict or just he just was oh no
i was you triggered something in me and
i wanted to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] to him
and so i said well you're a [ __ ] pill
addict you're not perfect either
so go ahead and play the clip i know
he's not i know he's not okay good
very good that's all the concept okay
it's all good yeah i'll square as she
says
even though i did i turned out okay
unfortunately just because you make
money
but you're way you're way crazier than
me
that's not true bro that's objectively
you're
you hide it more just like mikey who
hides [ __ ] oh really
gets brought to the circle i don't hide
anything i literally don't you've
literally just said how honest i am and
you respect
that about it but you hide the crazy is
what i'm saying yeah you you care a lot
i don't hide you do hi there i'm all out
there with no [ __ ] eyebrows and
everything you were into pills you never
talk about that that you were a pill
addict for a minute
what yeah you said that you said you
were really into pills and you don't
talk about that
why do i need to talk about that because
that's being open that you're judging me
for being crazy
taking pills or whatever like i take
pills or whatever but you've done it too
and you're just not open about it
i don't think that that is a defining
characteristic of who i am i think that
is a big thing that makes sense why
because you're on medication now and
there's no shame or judgment in it but
like hey if you're going to shame me for
being
you should say hey i'm on meds i'm not
shaming you for being off beds
um that's what it sounds like you just
call me crazy but here's my mom
you know what you just did you're trying
to see this is why you
are such a dangerous person especially
to be close with because you'll take
something that i've told you and you'll
take something that somebody told you in
confidence
and you'll use it you'll weaponize it
against them that's not true that's what
you just did
and luckily for you i don't care and i'm
okay with it but you go oh well you're i
told you an anecdote about how i used to
take like
what's like tramadol back in israel when
i was like bored in a dead-end job
and you literally just weaponized that
against me you called me crazy
knowing my history
and and also a little bit of context
she's dating my brother-in-law
because i was because i was like hey
just so you know she does this
okay can you hold that slow down slow
down slow roll
so first of all watching uncle fester
attack you was a little weird
that was a little much for me look good
though right it was remarkable uh you
sure you weren't a child star
wasn't gary
is it the is it the trauma that you see
that makes you think i was a child star
no no the actual actor who played uh
uncle fester i believe was a child stuff
oh really
um i think so so check me on that dan
check it out somebody somebody ian look
look it up
um but uh so that was harsh on both your
sides right
um trish here here's the thing
uh it's really hard to be as open
as trish is okay and you could argue
that you're so
open trish that you don't really kind of
perceive boundaries
normally if that makes sense is that is
that true
you knew you were being a [ __ ] hold on
don't start with the used stuff stop it
i'm wondering again that you knew you
were being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] here can i say like like hindsight
i look back and i was like oh yeah that
was [ __ ] up
but ethan for all the shows i don't
think we had any boundaries between us
he calls me fat
he tells me my boyfriend shouldn't be
with me i shouldn't have kids
and trisha can't do that she can't she
can't really
perceive boundaries it's just out there
it's all open well you can do it but you
can't expect her to
magically know where to draw the line
but can i also say he has no boundaries
with me he can say whatever he wants
about me
the minute like he okay there was an
issue this is a whole different issue
but i had an issue with my boyfriend
which is his brother-in-law with private
dms
he exposed all these private things so
there's no boundaries when it comes to
me
as soon as i bring up something private
with him then what triggered me was he's
like whoa you're weaponizing oh my god
you're being able to yeah i never
watched when i say anything no no you
told me i was weaponizing when all of a
sudden i thought that was our
relationship just saying whatever just
everything's out in the open so i was
like
that's what i thought so she's confused
it confuses her to not know
where you're supposed to draw the line
right now but don't you see
why me now would never con never say
anything like that to you in private
i can see that but the same thing you
read private text messages i sent only
to you
hold on hold on ethan ethan not saying
things in private to her because of that
does not make you an open person
right you can't say i'm totally open
about everything but i can't trust you
so i'm not gonna
i'm not okay you don't have to tell
everybody everything but don't claim
that you're wide open and telling
everybody everything
she's she's the one that's really wide
open too much too much so right
i agree i don't agree with that i've
seen i've seen her naked she's way too
wide open so he can call me crazy he can
do all this stuff and it's fine like
honestly because i have a lot of mental
i went to a mental hospital last year
like i have a lot of issues and so i but
and calling me crazy
talk about that word let's talk about
the word how do you because because you
keep
it you feel it like it's a negative like
a pejorative right because there's a way
to
own it like like the word addict or
junkie just going to
use it in comedy you can do that i use
it
we've called each other crazy so many
times and then all of a sudden it was a
problem not a trigger
but then when you were like i'm open and
i'm like oh are you and you're like
saying i'm open i'm open so then i'm
like well what about this and you
brought up stuff about me in private so
i thought it was okay to do it
so the minute you say wow i can't
believe you would do that i was like
what are you talking about you just
talking no
there's there's things you've told me in
private that i would never bring out
that you've told me about certain things
about your relationship with people
about moses was really really personal
and it's like it's really difficult it
was not
yes it was everybody said literally not
public
what are you guys talking about
specifically the the the arm thing
how did people get photos of it i didn't
put that up you said it on the podcast
that account was like now that it's out
on the podcast i'm gonna post these
photos my boyfriend got catfished by
someone
said something about an altercation we
had that nobody knew ethan brought it up
on the podcast that makes me look like
i'm a domestic abuse like i'm
a person that hits my partner and like
that was on the opening we even said
moses like stop cut it we're like don't
put that in the thing what does he do he
puts it in the [ __ ] thing
it was never it was never [ __ ] public
well maybe he shouldn't hit him
i agree but that is something that is so
[ __ ] personal that you said and we're
like please edit it out
it was a [ __ ] weak moment and our
relationship will never get past that i
even tell them that now everyone thinks
i'm a [ __ ]
like a man beater and [ __ ] like that
because of you and it's fine it's like
relationships it is ethan you are the
one who said it and you're like
you're the okay you did you said while
he was here everything can be said and
i'm like yeah because i thought that was
our relationship so the minute i say
something about your pill
hold on before i said it i said i i was
like how much of this can i read
because i don't want to upset you and
she said to me hey guys
hey hey let's navigate these waters
carefully or trisha is going to have
another episode of walking home i just
get like
frustrated navigate carefully navigate
carefully right
take a breath so we don't want to get to
the point we have another episode
of walking i know i am fine for real
it's frustrating when he's like no it's
already out there when moses and i both
know it wasn't
i didn't know that's what he was going
to say we have the ability to edit
things out and he didn't
just like the pill thing you could edit
it out you guys are but this is a
problem
this is the problem of a show like this
where you're you know you're playing
with being
totally out there with everything when
there are a few things that maybe not
and you guys got to be
very clear can you both agree that at
least
attempt going forward that when there
are things that
should not go out you'll both agree
these things don't go out
or just edit it out let me say because
you guys just left and it and it seemed
like you were fine with it being open if
you stayed and we're like cut
can you cut that out i would have done
that we did say we did ask you cut out
you're like no we're leaving this in
fine no i didn't say that fine yes you
did you did say that you're like no
we're not
we watch it back you literally because
that's what you said when i asked you
don't show my personal finances and you
did anyway well that was different okay
okay fine we left we can't keep up with
all this
i'm trying to keep up but i understand
why trisha is upset well hold on
thank you and then we guess what i was
okay with it because i'm like this is
our relationship this is what makes the
show
good right you're exposing [ __ ] stop
there stop with that
so you see that's the that's the
confusing part you've signed up for this
and it just went and it went too far no
but here's the thing i'm totally fine
the minute i said something that went
too far with ethan
all of a sudden i he said you weaponize
things this is the problem with you and
i was like
what the [ __ ] you've been doing this for
me every time i've seen you
that's all he does is expose private
information about me which again i
signed up for i'm
i literally am okay i own up to so much
awful things that i've done it's fine by
me truly it's fine by me but the minute
someone's like wow trish is crazy oh
trisha did this
it happened in my last relationship the
minute i spoke up i was uncomfortable
about a threesome
all of a sudden it's like wow trish it
was a joke wow okay you did that to
david and jade like
i'm the [ __ ] i'm the person that's
the villain i'm the oh my god you went
too far you weaponized this is why i'm
scared for moses to be in a relationship
with you
it's like that's our banter that was my
banter with my last relationship that's
ours and i thought it was fine
and then so my trigger wasn't that oh
and i [ __ ] up like the pill thing yeah
probably i should
because if it really was as big a deal
as we're making it
was it that big a deal well clearly
i didn't perform for you for you oh that
that
that that he had like a bruise on his
arm no that she came out with the pill
stuff
no it was more i was more like shocked
and surprised that she went
okay okay so why did you then hit her
with hey you're attacking me you're
weaponizing this information
because that's what triggered her
because she
already she does i mean you do that you
you don't you don't
okay so okay so fine so what is that
wait wait wait so what is that trisha
what's he talking about
i guess he says that i oh like i've done
exposed videos about my boyfriend's in
the past where it's like when i'm hurt
like i will do things like hurt people
or whatever like that which so so okay
so stop
so that maybe is not okay right i agree
i totally because you've never heard the
phrase
i don't know okay he's talking about my
boyfriend wait i interject i know listen
hold on that's a different issue
but hurt people hurt people right of
course you've heard that it's not of
course you you can deal with it a little
more productively
no i go to i go to dbt classes and so i
know my issue is okay
um it's like a group therapy for
electrical it's called dialectical
behavioral therapy and it helps
keep other people in mind when you want
to do something
because i have i have a really i can't
control myself it's almost like i black
out and like so when i
when i get mad or upset or i felt and
that was position i all of a sudden i
started feeling like wow i'm being like
looked at as the villain like i did
something wrong
okay so there's a lot here right yeah
and she's and ethan she's doing
something active about it she's actually
getting treated yeah i know that makes
me happy to hear so
yeah so good so i think we can move past
that a little bit because that shouldn't
happen as much right i do have
i do have a lot of empathy and sympathy
for
like the fact that sometimes you lose
control and you get really emotional
and you do and say things that you
regret i do want to add
that this whole event came after
they are her and her boyfriend got into
a fight and she already made a video
about him accusing him of flirting with
underage girls
which she's since retracted it's totally
different first of all it's totally
different because that's something
completely different than me
having an altercation with who's my
brother-in-law my wife's brother by the
way someone i care about
so so he's saying like i i made a video
being like you know he flirted with fans
whatever but that's a completely
different thing that i already made
public
as opposed to an altercation like that's
a completely different thing that
nobody wanted out there and you put out
there and then it went to the [ __ ] sort
of thing of trisha's abuser
and all this stuff which was not
something that was out there so let's go
so what ethan seems to appreciate is
when you have something
that becomes excessive you do something
active in response to it so what
what are you doing to help make sure
that doesn't happen again is that part
of the dbt therapy
yeah and well yes i mean i go to i
started that in may because
let me ask you a harsh question when
when people
you know when they get into altercations
that go that far oftentimes we advise
that they just
this isn't going to work is that the
case with this relationship
or are you both in it and working
actively with professionals to help make
sure it doesn't happen again yeah i'm
working now on it and it's like a thing
that's like super super sensitive
because it's never i've never
gone that far you know and i've gotten
help for the past year because i had
two mental hospital stays where i was
put on a 5150 so like i go into these
like cubes these states yeah like
it's like a blackout where i'm like not
that person yes
and like that was the first time that
happened so now that that's out there on
the internet
like everyone thinks that just me that i
just like abuse people and it's like
it's never been that far right so so
let's be clear
it's very much the same thing those
blackouts or white out or red outs that
people get when they hurt themselves and
other people
yeah and it needs to be treated you're
treating it
i mean that's the thing now now it's
also a sign of like really heavy-duty
childhood trauma so
are you getting that treated too not so
much yet i mean because i had my
blackout moments where i woke up and i
was like i didn't want to do that no
no i get it i get it
and so that's that's i don't want to do
that i don't want to hurt anyone even in
my relationship now i
i am trying to like sabotage it to not
make it last because i don't want to be
harmful to anybody and i am i'm
dangerous to myself i'm dangerous to
other people and it's
it's bad okay so stop so and so ethan
can you see how when you say something
like this is a weaponized you're
attacking me
that's that's tough territory for her
right now you got it
yeah no i understand okay yeah so so
here's the deal
um you have you're doing dbt do you do
you have do you have any like
uh peer support that kind of thing
people can call when you start to ask
okay so you're doing all the right stuff
right you have a therapist you have a
dbt
group yeah you're got peer support i
mean
it's you know the fact that this
happened from my perspective
not so surprising given what you what
you tell everybody about yourself
yeah that's part of this whole syndrome
and yes you have to be extremely careful
you can't you have to
five steps earlier you have to do
something
to make sure you don't get all the way
to those dissociative states what we do
that's what it is i mean what we do now
and by the way by the way
you're hanging in very very well with
this whole episode
we're all going through here you're not
dissociating which is kind of remarkable
right
thank you i i feel like we have worked
on it since i mean we i tell him like
because he i used to tell him like hey
let's stop talking about this and he
took it as me just trying to control the
situation but now if i say can we please
stop talking about this like he does
because i know that's when i get into
that like blackout thing because that's
what happened i was like can we just
stop talking about
and when we when he doesn't because he
thinks i'm trying to control the
conversation which i don't know
you have to say you have to you need a
code word you need some way of stopping
it
come back around later escalating and
that's what we do and that's what it has
been it's just one of those things that
i've never gone that far where i just
feel like
i shouldn't be in a relationship i
shouldn't you know not for a while
that's all that that said all that
negative self-talk i know that's part of
the problem right
and so and so ethan the good news is you
and her relationship has never gone to
those places
right so she obviously trusts you no not
quite
not quite well no we had a really bad
blowout on a few episodes ago where i
think you were
starting to disassociate and you left i
walked out because he
was pushing it once again he wouldn't
let go we were 20 minutes past our thing
and i'm like you know what i'm going to
just i'm going to leave after this i'm
going to leave it after this and he's
like
no let's resolve this i was trying i was
trying to apologize but
let me solve not right now not right now
like i'm gonna just leave i'm just gonna
leave and he would not end it so i
that's when i walked out i didn't get
angry
i didn't yell at him i was like more
embarrassed than anything and i just
left and it was past our time of doing
the show i stayed in there for the rest
of it
and i just left because that was what he
was saying the weaponizing thing and i
just i just i knew it was gonna like
set me off and i already did and that's
why i was being nasty about his wife and
his kids and stuff like and i was like
okay i need to like leave because i know
it's gonna get even worse but i don't
take that stuff personally because
you know i understand can i have a hug
by the way no not only
now i don't think that's right i don't
think that's the thing right now
really not this time for a hug no i
don't think so
we might get there but we're not there
and he's never hugged me ever once can i
just say that so if you hug me now it's
just in genuine to me
really it's going to seem like ever
because you never have any
when you're dressed as one another it's
actually yeah well then
with a lack of not with in and uh
and replacement of hugging you well no i
seeing you like this
i mean it it gives me a life insight
yes i think ethan's saying i i see how
tender this is i apologize where i've
triggered it too far
that's what she needs lots of right now
yeah i understand well i was just you
know
no i i i mean i mean i i
think it's just like i always feel bad
like i always and i haven't apologized
to you when i am i do
i do feel bad when i attack like your
wife and you're like you're like all
that stuff like that
i do feel bad right away like that's the
worst thing about this is like
i feel bad instantaneously i'm like [ __ ]
i like what i'm i'm such a bad person
like this is why i don't keep friends
and he said in that same episode
this this is why nobody wants to be with
you and it's like that all there is like
i know this stuff it's like i just can't
control it right now i'm doing better at
it but like i don't have friends i don't
have relationships that last longer than
year he knows that
so by you saying that too it just like
[ __ ] triggered it all over again
because i know that's why i don't have
friends i know that
well and i feel bad instantaneously like
i'm talking about
them talk it's all good no i think i
feel bad and i feel like
i didn't it's hard i feel like people
misun mis perceive you and misunderstand
you
i think people think that you're not
self-aware or that you're just like this
wrecking ball
and that you kind of are just like this
emotionless creature that just smashes
everything up and
you don't think twice about it yeah but
it's clear to me now that
that you are very aware of how you can
be
hurtful and and mess things up and that
it does hurt you
yeah and i and i understand about how i
said
you know at that time was maybe just
hitting
was hitting too hard and was was just
too mean and it was something that that
you are you know painfully aware of yeah
um here's here's the deal
you still have to have a show yeah i
still have to have a show and you still
have to conflict
but i think you got to do a little more
agreeing on the where the boundaries are
you know
and now you understand and once you
trigger what's under all that can i ask
you
a question that i think is may come off
as insensitive but i think it's okay
and before you do i just want to say
this would be a very different
conversation
were she not doing active professional
interventions on all of this
yeah she's doing the care she needs to
do to make this better i am very proud
of you that you're doing all that stuff
i think that's
great so what's your question is it not
at least somewhat my place to worry that
you know with all that with like
you know the the the problems that you
have that you're working on and that we
all understand and
um is it not inappropriate for me to
worry about my brother-in-law being in a
relationship with her
oh oh i mean i don't know i don't want
to know the details of what you know how
bad it's gotten between
them uh that's really his decision right
i mean it's it's she is doing active
interventions i i mean maybe he's
naughty yes
who is he yeah he's he's co-signing
yeah he's here okay but uh but trish do
you guys do anything together
therapeutically um we have it
um and it's more just because i do talk
a lot about like
um like childhood trauma that i don't
talk about with anybody not on my
youtube so i kind of just don't want
them to know everything like because my
parents a lot of my parents
like my both my parents don't really
know all of it so it's just like
something i don't
want him to know right now okay that's
fine that's fine
then he kind of he should see a
therapist as well
so he again because boundaries are
really goofy you know
he needs to get some clarity about that
he needs to understand where his
he's at and where you know what's you
what's him you understand how that gets
kind of
blurry right yeah i mean he's yeah he
should see somebody too and then and
then you're
gonna then proceed you know you're you
treatment works guys
that's the other issue with ethan like
him being like should i be concerned i
mean his brother-in-law is 43 you know
what i mean 43 and yeah
yeah no matt like the thing is is like
the reality of the situation is like
he's here with me every week like we're
always together all the time it's like
why
and from the beginning even if it was a
joke or not on the podcast he's like i
don't approve of this
uh they should tell us what they're
doing and then i never said i didn't
approve
but the whole what happened was that he
have to own this okay we did a show on
the podcast called the bachelor which
we've done before where we set up
somebody and we have content you know
the bachelor
yeah so trisha was the bachelorette and
they started
hanging out trisha
don't don't you're okay you're starting
to sink on us you're welcome
i'm really i'm okay i really there's
just a lot happening with like the look
and then you and then the guests and
then
all this right now no i know and don't
don't don't let it depress you it's all
good
it's all good i'm not okay i feel good
look what's sitting in front of you
right stupid
hang on stay in the moment okay here we
go so finish up okay
i just saw you singing there and i
didn't want that to happen when she
adjusts her blouse i was
because there's fake nips here oh you
have to blur that
you're gonna have to blur that down i
asked if she adjusted her dress
it's like right above your nip right
yeah yeah because you want to show as
much cleavage as possible
without the titty ethan also once told
me i had the worst boob job ever
so but that didn't offend you did it the
thing is is like
yes and no like that's our relationship
i know you're joking it's like love i'm
fine with you doing it but at the same
time it is offensive so it's like when i
say something like offensive like
it's like whoa no no no you're i've you
can tell me whatever you want it's just
the pill thing that i found
curious okay and now we're going to do
the only time you guys need to be able
to offend each other to do this [ __ ]
and i love it like i love when people
make jokes and i was okay with they're
saying that dr drew if you recall i said
you know
i'm i'm fine i just find it curious you
didn't say that you're like wow you're
weaponizing right now this is what i'm
concerned about moses like
that in addition to all the other things
i just said okay but anyway let's go
back
let's let's go back to when they started
dating okay
um they started dating
and moses at first was saying he was
just doing it for the show
he thought it would be entertaining for
the show okay this has all been said so
i don't think i'm hurting anyone
no you're fine and so i don't believe
that necessarily but go ahead
right you don't believe what he said or
what i'm saying what he's that he said
just doing it for the show
he said that he's just what
so anyway they they were started posting
these pictures this happened over the
course of a few weeks
and every time we saw we see moses a lot
it's my wife's brother and he says oh
it's nothing it's nothing we're just
hanging out yada yada
and um this lash is all in my eye
oh my god and what they put up with
yeah it's crazy
and and so he was being deceptive to us
and so we didn't know what was happening
and it's not that i disapproved it's
just that we were having the show with
trisha and seeing moses all the time
and they were being deceptive to us and
maybe they felt like they didn't want to
be judged by us and all that and i get
it
but that was the reason why i never said
i disapproved i just thought
it was weird that you guys were like
sneaking around and not telling us what
was going on
lying to us you say i disavowed this
that's exactly what you said that's your
quote exactly
well i was probably you know being i
don't know why
it's not you can't just say oh that was
a joke i have i have always actively
said
that i prove i don't have a problem i
just don't like the deception
but we were just about to date like what
are we supposed to be like we're
boyfriend girlfriend like
well it was really moses's fault i don't
blame you on that one moses was
very disappointed bottom line why is it
your concern even now you're like should
i be confused
if there was no show i wouldn't care
right now we're doing a show and you're
like she has a mental health authority
we're doing a date show okay right now
in this moment you just said should i be
concerned for my brother-in-law because
i have issues with my mental health
you know what it's not it was
insensitive and i think dr drew had a
really good response that i agree with
and it is moses's
choice and i and i support his choice
and and he has to keep up with you is
what i'm saying he's got to be in his
own treatment because
yeah i mean you know because you're
going to change and um
you don't believe in therapy do you
we're doing just fine he says they're
doing just fine
in response to does he believe in there
interesting maybe a little allen on for
moses
what did you say maybe a little alanon
what do you think christian
a what an honor what is that
i don't know what that is for it's for
people that are involved with people
that have used substances
oh okay and and it's you know it's to
get some support and get some clarity on
what they're doing i don't think moses
would ever do that
no it doesn't sound like it okay let's
not talk about him though and also for
the record
my parents also are not about you know
what i mean my mom more so but like my
dad's not about therapy so i had
i go on these alone when i was like i
you know i've had other issues with
addiction and like i went on my own when
i was in mental hospital i was on my own
no one you know my mom came to see me
but
i didn't thank god thank god you're
doing this yeah but
i'm usually alone with it and that's why
i'm like you know it's okay
you know despite everything i've always
wished the best for you and i really do
love you as a friend
yeah i feel like we have amazing
chemistry and i see the goodness
in you and i know that like you're
always fighting
to and to bring that out more than like
when you get
upset or you do this and that and the
stuff you regret like that doesn't i've
all
i don't ever see that as who you are i
know i know who you are and i
love that person as a friend of mine
okay thank you
you're welcome pretty good
yeah all right let's get back to the
drama
we still didn't solve what we're doing
with the word crazy right we're using it
or not using it
because i think you're sure like this
yeah i think this you kind of have to
you have to own it and say you're using
it because you need the you need
craziness because that's what you're
sort of
creating here in the studio i love it a
certain amount of craziness yeah and
that didn't trigger me so when i said
when he said i'm so open and so open i
finally was just like but you're not
because this is what you're not open
about and then what the trigger was the
weaponizing all of a sudden i'm the
villain
i know you got it he got it too which is
the good news okay
now let's face it this would you imagine
ethan when you asked me to come here
i don't know i i i think i was expecting
it to be more light-hearted i guess but
this show i was going to call you i was
going to call you i
told you yes i emailed yesterday today i
think we should get on the phone because
it
it either it either doesn't work at all
or it gets heavy
that's what happens with this kind of
thing and it's much better when it gets
real
i agree no i love talking i like talking
about it i especially like talking like
with someone who like understands it
because i think the whole internet
thinks
i'm crazy i'm a liar i'm this i'm
destructive and so like it's nice to
just hear like
at least you understand that there are
people like me out there which is like
oh
i i sort of specialize in people like
you i know
you made a career you used to see a lot
of folks like that you know
but you know they did well you know yeah
trisha gets a lot of [ __ ] on the
internet from a lot of people
and i think that it's important
for more people to see you like this
because i
think that people really i think it's a
really good insight to you as a
vulnerable real feeling emotional person
and not just like
the wrecking ball that people think you
are people just think you're a mess
and that you just you know are
destructive and this and you just do
everything for attention
well it's not unwarranted though like i
understand why people think
the things i do are for attention
because i i have always been an
attention seeker i've always needed
attention
more than most people so i get it i
understand i said offensive things way
in my past that will haunt me forever
you know what i mean like it's like
i get why people don't like me it's not
like i'm not aware of it
it's just more like how do i change the
perception if i ever can i know i never
will be able to fully change people
always think i'm problematic
or something you know what i mean like
it's part of your brand but i do think
it's
great it's important to see but you know
that you're more than that i'm just
self-aware and i i know it's not
unwarranted i'm not trying to be like
i'm like
there's not everything wrong with me
like i know i do stuff that's
problematic but that was when i was in
my 20s you know i'm 32 and i'm trying to
like do
better and stuff but it's it's you know
so we've named a lot of the stuff that
you've been dealing with
do you give a name to the overall
syndrome that you're dealing with or do
you
talk about that no well here's the other
thing i mean not to make this all about
my therapist there was another drama
so the other thing was is i i don't
my therapist that i talk to he i ask him
straight up i'm like on my borderline
and my bipolar like in my schizo like
there's
you know all these things and he's like
well you have traits of a lot of things
so i can't really say
it's one you know you're you're
definitely bipolar i've been on
medication to treat bipolar
um because but there's also so my my my
scandal
everyone hated me for this year and it's
still something that like triggers me in
a really dark deep way and i talk with
my boyfriend about it because only
people close to me see it is
is the disassociative identity disorder
which i've talked about before
and i saw a video about it on youtube so
i made a reply being like i think i
might have traits of this like this
sounds like something that i do
and everybody came for me it's like
trisha just wants attention she's making
a mockery out of it and the original
initial video was very sincere
and the minute people thought i was
making a mockery of it then i was like
okay let me make a mockery of this and
let me just
disassociate where i'm like all of a
sudden like i'm a little baby whatever
people wanted to see
i just i made a mockery of it because i
was like trying to say it in a very
authentic way like this is what's
happening and i don't go into characters
or whatever you know whatever that
happens to other people
it doesn't happen with me but when i do
go off on people it's literally like a
different person any boyfriend of mine
my last boyfriend jason my boyfriend now
will say it's a different person like
it's
and i don't know who it is and like when
i said that everyone's like
[ __ ] you trisha for using mental health
that's like getting attention and stuff
and it was literally just a reply to
someone's video
i totally agree with you in that one the
amount of [ __ ] you got for that was
[ __ ] up because
whether you actually have that or not i
mean who knows i mean you
you you could say better but it's hard i
know it's hard difficult sometimes
to diagnose specific mental disorders
but like the amount of [ __ ] people gave
you was so messed up
especially considering it's like i think
we can all agree that
you're trying to define some kind of
issue that you have well
let me let me help sort of refine it
because she has told us that the person
who's seeing her
says she doesn't have a diagnosable
personality disorder as yet but she has
traits of certain personality disorders
right
and when you talk about the dissociating
which you mentioned earlier you were
suicidal in a dissociative state right
that that's sort of more consistent with
the borderline stuff
as well as the rages and the in the
inability to control yourself in certain
times that's all sort of borderline
stuff
and the dbt is designed to treat that
yeah right so you're into you're in a
good therapy for that
whether or not you have dissociative
identity disorder you know people argue
about whether that even exists
sometimes just people see that as severe
borderline a borderlines can present
differently to different people
and differently in different mood states
and you're aware you're doing that
right and the idea you know hopefully in
therapy is you sort of integrate all
those parts so they don't come apart
when you have really intense feelings
make sense yeah that maybe it makes
sense to me and that's
yeah yeah and my therapist had told me
the same thing he's he's one that
doesn't necessarily believe in like the
disassociative of like going into
different altars
you know because i don't i've seen some
crazy stuff and you don't have anything
like that
yeah yeah right so i think that's why
people are like no and so when people
said no then i did troll and make a
video where i started going into altars
if that's what people wanted to see but
it was clearly a troll
people were upset that i you know did
that and i get that i get it i get the
upset with that but that mean it
triggered from people being like you
don't have this you don't have this
meanwhile everyone's saying you're crazy
you have this you have everyone
diagnosing me it's like well
can i ask you a question yeah when you
make a video like that or the trans
reader or whatever
you get a lot of attention you're you're
an attention seeker but you get
you usually it you usually get a lot of
negative attention
do you see a difference between negative
and positive attention
yeah that's what i was saying it's like
my trans video and my did video were
never to be negative they were never to
get negative attention and i got
my last one where i willingly seeked out
negative attention was like
when trump ran the first time i was like
hey i'm a trump supporter i'm not and
that's when i was like oh i'm gonna be
and i loved getting negative attention
back then that was when six four years
ago so it was like
i haven't done a negative attention
seeking video sense because you know why
people try and kill me there's like
stalkers that come to my house and it
scared me and i didn't want to do that
anymore and so so is it possibly that
you
you can accept negative attention when
it's not something that really
represents you
but when it's about something you're
trying to be honest about then that's
really upsetting when you get that
negative attack i don't like negative
attention period
i used to like it and i use it but i
don't need attention anymore i don't
make my money off youtube
you know i don't make my money can i i
don't think let's let's
drill in a little further ethan for some
reason this sounds like something
important to you i don't think you're
quite getting it
across i don't think trish is quite
answering it so
what is it you actually want to know
ethan
like when you seeking attention are you
because are you literally curious can
she tell the difference between
negative and positive sometimes it feels
just curious you're just curious of your
problems is that
you seek attention and sometimes you
don't care if it's or maybe you can't
distinguish if it's good or bad or if
it's going to result in good or bad
i distinguish it but once last time i
was like looking for negative attention
well i don't know but i'm just saying
you keep having these issues
it results from like the d.i.d and the
transiting resulting from
not people like you but people saying
well you said you were a chicken nugget
seven years ago when you had a meth
problem
it's like that's why because they can't
take it seriously from them can i also
add i know the difference though
those are usually your most popular
videos too
um yeah and like i said the trans one i
like immediately regret it i apologize
the next day i have an apology video i'm
so sorry i said this like
that's not what i meant okay you guys
are talking kind of a past each other
so so trish when i met you you were very
proud of some of your negative stuff
well that that that's kind of stayed
with me i noticed that i think that's
what ethan's sort of
interested in what you know and and what
i would what i'm wondering
shall i say that even i'm wondering what
i'm wondering
yeah i'll never get there but i know i'm
up there
what i'm wondering is if you can own
some of the stuff
some part of what brings on the
negativity oftentimes
you ever heard of traumatic reenactments
no
i don't think okay okay so there's a
crazy thing we do as human beings if we
were traumatized in childhood
we drift into relationships and
circumstances
where we recreate the same thing that
was so upsetting to us as a child
so you might look at some of these
negative interactions to see if there's
something you're attracted to
which it's all about attraction from the
trauma you get attracted to that
that you can watch out for that sets you
up to re-traumatize yourself and get all
that negative attention that's all i'm
saying
yeah like publicly you mean if that's
what if you want to change it i mean
he's been sort of wondering if you want
to change it i think behind that he's
wondering
do you really want all that negative
attention yeah but then he's he but then
he's ambivalent because he wants you to
get
a lot of attention and it's always a
negative attention but here's the thing
i'm kind of just like numb to it you
know i'm i'm
i'm you i'm just like so used to just
people hating me anyways
and i know what i'm doing for myself and
like who i am so i think it's kind of
one of those things
so i yeah i think i i i want to change
it ideally i would ideally like southern
ideally i wouldn't like people to hate
me but i know that's just
literally going to be whatever i do is
going to be problematic even if it's
something so small like me liking my
chemical romance this year all the
emails were like [ __ ] you for liking
this or like
theater kids they tweet lemon while
miranda and say oh [ __ ] her for liking
hamilton like people just
don't like me for whatever i do they
don't want you in their club yeah
there's one more thing i want to uh
address before we wrap it up here i know
you're on a deadline
pull up this clip here uh
from our latest episode i believe this
was our very last episode
when we so when we address i wouldn't
predict you two to be friends you know
that
really yeah no i i know what you mean
but like so
and i admire that you are i like that
sir he's like my best friend he's like a
cancer what would you say
about me my best friend smash and
shane's a cancer and they're very likely
i think i need to see you guys in the
wild like have coffee with you sometime
or something and see what really is
going on here
i know maybe we don't see each other in
the wild this is it yeah yeah
okay pull up this clip from our last
episode
go ahead whenever you're ready ian
unless you're at the bathroom
hold on let me adjust my titties as um
do you
it's pretty fun right it's pretty fun
it's awesome it's a good time
these feel pretty good you want to feel
my no come on feel my teeth no
boundaries feel my titties
just go with the clothes are you working
on this we gotta go
okay okay you wow i was just like wow
you know that seems like a low blow what
you did okay but it's perfectly fine
that what you did then exposing our
personal stuff that i would never have
said to anyone
saying that i hit someone and left
bruises on their arms it wasn't public
that was never public no one said
anything about it
sorry i'm not getting this to be cute it
literally just keeps getting in my eyes
i swear no one thinks you look cute it's
fine no i
i don't i'm not trying to look cute it
literally keeps the hair is the worst
part
um anyways i have a blast on so i'm not
crying
the um well yeah you know i have i have
a lot to apologize for for sure
no you did apologize yeah i am sorry i
didn't like the way
that the podcast ended i felt really bad
i mean people said i would i mean people
were more on your side than my side on
that one saying that i shouldn't have
gone for your family but i'm not i'm not
apologizing
you don't apologize for anything no so
what do i call you
thoughts that was uh her in another one
of her states what was that all about
yeah and i made a video following up the
one they accidentally played before this
was me
apologizing literally the day that came
out because i don't know i literally
don't know anyone who knows this i'm
like i don't know
you're in a state you were in some sort
of rigid state that you couldn't get out
of
it was awful and i felt so bad and i
made an apology video the same day it
came out
i don't know why i was like that i tried
to like i just was trying to be tough i
guess i still felt like
i'd attacked yeah i don't know what that
was either but that does not seem
consistent with who you want to be at
least
no and i issued an apology in the in the
video after and
um yeah i don't know i literally don't
know who it was everyone in the comments
like trisha so nasty
it felt like it felt like literally
remember that
movie cocoon it felt like you were
literally in one of those
was that the feeling you had that's like
you were in a
go ahead yeah i mean it literally just
feels like it's
it's like on autopilot where i'm just
like i don't even know what i'm saying
like in the moment i literally feel like
i shouldn't be doing this
i sound like a [ __ ] this is not who i
am and i just like yeah it's like you're
like you're not even there you're just
inside this
chrysalis and then we're just talking to
the outside of the cocoon and it's just
repeating stuff over and over again so
you know you're going to be there again
well the good news is though
that i'm here now if you have something
to say
i do i said it in the video did you were
pulled it up i didn't well i'm here i
don't need to watch another
video i do i feel horrible i i do
apologize for
being so nasty like from the pill thing
because i know how that feels and i
apologize
for not for trying to be tough and
badass and talking about ela and
everything i always feel bad
like i feel bad about it when it's not a
joking mode when it wasn't when you
triggered me i felt bad
when i was like good luck trying to get
your wife pregnant like it was just a
mean thing i don't know what it was and
i'm sorry and i i
i feel bad like that's not me thank you
i feel like it would feel better for you
to apologize and get it out of here
because i know you don't mean it no i
know no i felt bad it's just like in
that moment
i felt like i do forgive you okay thank
you
um was that gloria steinem who were you
oh jeffree star gloria
yeah jeffree star look him up okay okay
i'm just so used to his dresses here
[Laughter]
jeffree star or well she's sitting here
so it's awkward don't answer that
don't answer that actually
unprofessional stupid
yeah but they changed i said my mic
dropped off okay i'm back okay
okay it's too much for me this is too
much for you guys it's a lot
well the good news is that we're done
okay good it's a lot but it was a
privilege
it was a privilege i feel like we're
ending this show on a better note than
we've probably
done i feel great i was very excited to
have you here doctor
no oh my god
is it your husband will come one of
these guys squeeze my titty
no no no no one of these days would be
hard one of these days yeah
we didn't get into any of the physical
boundary stuff
that's way down the line yeah that's
later
all right so ethan aren't you glad you
asked me yeah
no i thought doctor i was going to call
him and warn him i knew it i knew it was
going to happen
the world famous dr drew you can find
him on dr drew after dark on your mom's
house
podcast as well as dr drew youtube
channel where he does a daily show check
him out he's uh
he's a periscope facebook it's
everywhere go doctor.com you can check
it out doctor
tv it's all everywhere it's everywhere
god damn it just google dr drew
yeah i'd love to have dr drew come back
and administer some personality tests to
us
those are really fun but one thing at a
time for him to do
everybody though everybody yeah we have
a whole crew it would be so fun to get
all their personality test because you
can do like narcissism you could do
sociopath
yeah yeah while we're waiting while we
were waiting for trish i sent out a sos
to the guy that uh i do these kinds of
studies with to see what he can come up
with and
i'll let oh it's going to be fun yeah
it's going to be silver yeah yeah i'm
down
all right well thank you guys everyone
for joining this is our final
uh halloween episode yeah so have a
happy halloween everybody
yay and um stay safe
and pray that california doesn't burn
down before the next time
yeah that's our house are you ever going
to take that wig off ethan you seem
really into that hair
he's doing it only feels good the other
one was too was in my this yeah
[Music]